bientôt s'excuse aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur world of squeeze c'est un
fan qui a créé ce jeu pour nous et on va
jouer tout de suite merci le fan auquel
un trop hauts les effets spéciaux
hu nous sommes en 2075 dans la galaxie
tva la terre n'existe plus les habitants
sont partis dans ta celle on a sondé
koné regarder quand même temps savez
j'en peux plus les planètes squeeze ces
partis allez on y va on va commencer
dans la contrée du départ aux as et un
truc type iv mario sessa oh ça commence
mais tu as tu prévu ce week-end c'est
une brique avec ma tête et je le fais
tous les jours au frais eh ben tu sais
quoi
tu es mal tombé je connais tous les
pièges de ce genre de jeu ok mais ça par
exemple sur il faut pas le prendre
voila voila je mettais sur faut tenter
vous savez faut tenter au plat y en a
qui va s'envoler hook voila voila c'est
prévisible alors oui je suis dit avec
oui mais je fais comment oh non tu es
tombé bien bas
ya pas de doute et un concept us et es
voilà je suis à le mec lui fait un joli
tout bio et toi tu sais que tu trouves à
faire c'est de reproches d'oise affreux
on la sent pas bon la chasse est maire
de marché scandaleuse voilà personne ne
marche comme ça même la journée la plus
beau but de l'année personnes marchent
comme ça avec tous ces trous sur moi
plus de problèmes pour respirer mais
j'ai adoré ta blague j'ai adoré dans la
douleur et dans la rage
non mais non il y en a on s'en fout on
s'en fout ce que j'allais dire ça nous
intéresse pas cette guerre est passé
c'est drôle on fait semblant de rien
parce que ça passe mieux que de rage et
comme une grosse merde non mais quoi
médias mais pas un piège là bas je suis
juste nul ou tout cela ne m'atteint pas
ok je suis régulièrement moi je vais
voir les brest et je grimpe
voilà vont tomber comme ça dans le vide
contrée du départ autrement appelée
contrée de l'échec autrement appelée
contrex aussi bouteilles d'eau aux
médias tassos cause à dos santos
concentre on y va au culot
oh oh attendez attendez cinématiques
cinématiques [ __ ] au les graphismes
aux purs et le soleil le jaune
ok flapi squeeze super on va craquer
appuyez sur entrée espace où cliquer
pour voler au maroc au [ __ ] tu crois
que j'aime tester la dureté d'un tuyau
n'ont pas vraiment moi j'ai un autre
tuyau qui dure et tu sais très bien où
il va finir si tu vois ce que je veux
dire
il fallait en mettre trois des tubes à
15 mangas mes toiles après son mettre la
pression c'est comme ça que tu marches
plus qu'à aller lui casser à la moitié
c'est la moitié soit quand tu t'es un
homme ça marche bien alors c'est un
salon de ce que je prenais il est vrai
mais on n'est plus à ça près o le
dernier hommage
c'est étrange le temps un peu plus loin
à l'air d'être violent normal près d'un
volcan en éruption
je dois pourtant pas ces annonces le
plus fait pas un truc de fdp
dirigez-vous avec le clavier à ok
d'accord je puisse esquiver les trucs
quoi ou ou ou oies ok ok pour dire à
pizza ce faire un truc qui veut aller
jusqu'à l'ovule normes watts avec ckoi
délire sans déconner quoi vous n'avez
qu'un mec a fait tomber des grains de
café sur la tête et je savais que
quelqu'un cette comparaison bien sûr que
non au nom des sept mois de cajou j'ai
vu il y avait une gravure sur le côté il
ya marqué quoi y'a marqué je te baise
me dis pas que le dessin de cette graine
de noix de cajou de merde c'était pas de
filiation mon crâne sans déconner non me
dis pas elle me dit me dis pas je te dis
là ça fait quoi
c'est comme si je fais pas tu marches
dans la rue là j'ai fait ce que par
exemple baird a affiché comprend une loi
de cannes et je vais faire mon dieu mon
doigt jamais aussi long et je vous jure
que jamais allé aussi loin
non mais mondia mais ça marche trop bien
ce qu'on fait là ça marche trop bien
regarder non cette fois on voit
l'arrivée du tout je me suis pris noah
j'ai entendu coucou et là haut au monde
et au monde et où 1 200 que là il ya un
potentiel finale pour finir je n'arrive
plus à plat non mais [ __ ] mais là je
suis tétanisé par la rage et tout se
passera bien
je sais qu'en cas d'incident dans ma vie
il faudra pas que je dise ça je suis
ressorti nul pas trop [ __ ] attendait
assez matticks vous plaît bordel j'ai
cru que j'allais y passer
tiens je me sens bizarre donc ne dit pas
que ma transformation et le mot moignon
quiconque comme un beauf est de retour
alors ça c'est quoi la caverne
ouais
bonjour je suis mal tombé
j'ai pas encore les mythes courir mais
plus haute est bien où suis-je dans une
caverne
bon je me relève et j'allume à l'emploi
ok j'ai pas envie de mourir ça al'air
longer pas une mourir oh [ __ ]
bonjour le perdre a battu l [ __ ] ok ok
on est bon on est bon et nous rattrape
dans la trappe
ta gueule d'ailleurs c'est génial je
suis tout ému de voir ça c'est génial
hodac où j'adore le jeu vraiment je
retire tout ce que j'ai dit c'est mary
du monde la langue bleue emmerdes elle
est là bonjour mon dieu c'est leur
boulot plus démoniaque que jamais vous
allez effectuer un combat voici quelques
règles en appuyant sur entrée vous
lancez du jambon c'est ce dernier touche
d'alors alors vous gagnez du charisme
mais si vous recevez des dégâts vous en
perdez c'est votre barre de charisme
évident vous perdez de la santé ok on va
lancer du jambon soir alors qu'on va
gagner un max de charisme à un max de
charisme m à l'aller on l'attend pour la
table matin pour la tap
[ __ ] [ __ ] ok j'ai la technique faut
sauter moment elle tire merde allez on
envoie des jambons que la butte et on va
la butte et [ __ ] soirée dans dark
souls dans plus de bornes à nom met un
petit coup sec dans la nuque là mon gars
moreau ses parts et je dois la technique
faut s'approcher comme sans lui tout
dans la gueule envers les membres garder
comme elle aime le jambon là on met des
noces comme jambes on emmerde
non mes mecs mais plus nous on va mourir
on va mourir fond sur sa proie en
meurent anna tient à pas dans mes
maigres regarder la vie qu'elle enlève
yes yes dieu et les plus démoniaques que
jamais au web elle est morte elle est
morte
waouh
cette première vidéo sur voir doc
squeeze j'espère si vous a plus c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude [ __ ] ça me plaît beaucoup
sur sa superbe touchant de jouer un jeu
qui reprend totalement l'univers qu'on a
créé tous ensemble c'est juste génial
donc un grand merci à baloche c'est le
pseudo du mec qui a créé ce jeu on le
finira dans une prochaine vidéo parce
que la tournée faut quand même que
j'adorais biberon à jumbo en soit
entamée dans une prochaine vidéo
mercenaires regarder portez vous bien
que tout le monde dise